madame la Première ministre laissez-moi
vous citer en tant que garde des saau
Éric Dupont moriti a toute ma confiance
et fait un excellent travail telle était
votre déclaration hier sur France
interre je conçois qu'il est difficile
pour vous d'admettre une nouvelle
affaire qui touche votre gouvernement
nouvelle et pas des moindres le ministre
de la Justice poursuivi par sa propre
justice c'est cfcayen c'est une
plaisanterie à part dans une République
où on a Emmanuel Macron comme président
et oui c'est possible c'est une première
dans la 5e République félicitations
continuez de congratuler votre garde d'
saau pour son excellent travail un garde
d'essau qui est soupçonné d'avoir
utilisé son ministère et les services
qui en dépendent pour régler ses comptes
un garde des saau qui depuis juillet
2021 est obsédé par sa défense un
recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel h pourvoies en cassation
ce qui représente des heures à éplucher
la jurisprudence de rendez-vous avec ses
avocats des heures pour préparer sa
défense des heures où il n'est pas
ministre un garde des saut qui pendant
15 jours sera empêché dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions un garde des saau qui
s'autorise non pas un mais deux bras
d'honneur dans cet hémicycle parce qu'un
président de groupe ose évoquer
finalement la procédure en cours un
garde des saau qui se pose en victime et
qui ose parler d'infamie quand son
action est interrogée madame la Première
ministre la jurisprudence baladure un
ministre mis en examen il démissionne
avait une raison d'être garantir qu'un
ministre à s' tâche pleinement
complètement au service des Français et
au service de l'État donc ma question
madame la Première ministre elle est
simple finalement qu'est-ce que ça fait
depuis mai 2022 de diriger un
gouvernement sans garde au D
saau je vous remercie la parole est à
madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre puté madame la Présidente
châtelin il y a dans notre État de droit
un principe auquel je tiens c'est la
présomption
d'innocence j'imagine madame la
Présidente châelin que vous y êtes
également attaché alors le ministre de
la Justice comme toutes et tous y a
droit le procès s'est ouvert hier et il
durera jusqu'au 16
novembre sur une affaire une procédure
en cours comme vous l'imaginez vais
faire aucun commentaire et pendant cette
période des mesures pratiques classiques
d'organisation ont été prises donc je
vous rassure la continuité de l'État et
de l'action gouvernementale est bien
assurée et je vous le redis madame la
président de châelin comme garde des
saut Éric Dupont morti à toute ma
confiance je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie madame la Première ministre
madame la Présidente merci madame la
Présidente oui comm ous ici nous sommes
attachés à la présomption d'innocence
mais la question est ce gouvernement
est-il attaché au principe de probité
aujourd'hui apparemment la réponse est
NON je vous
remercie